SCARLET: DON'T MISS THIS,
♪
MARK: I'M MARK HALPERIN.
JOHN: AND I'M JOHN HEILEMANN.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
DONALD TRUMP'S WALL, IT LOOKS
LIKE THE MEXICANS ARE COMING IN.
MR. TRUMP: THEY'RE GETTING READY
TO ATTACK.
♪
JOHN: ON THE SHOW TONIGHT, A
TARMAC CHAT.
BUT FIRST, DONALD TRUMP'S NEW
CAMPAIGN TECH.
HE DID SOMETHING REMARKABLE
TODAY, HE ALMOST COME A KIND OF
ACTED LIKE A NORMAL PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
HE HELD AN EVENT IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE THIS AFTERNOON WHERE
HE DELIVERED A SCRIPTED SPEECH
ON TRADE POLICY.
THE REPORTERS WERE FLOODED WITH
PRESS RELEASES FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN FILLED WITH FACTS AND
FIGURES TO BOLSTER TRUMPS
MESSAGE AND HIS REMARKS.
MR. TRUMP: WHEN YOU HAVE LARGE
NUMBERS OF UNEMPLOYED,
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS, INCOMES GO
DOWN NOT JUST -- GO DOWN ACROSS
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU FORCE THEM TO COMPETE
WITH THOSE EARNING ONE DOLLAR
AND OUR OVERSEAS, OUR WHOLE
STANDARD OF LIVING GOES DOWN.
WE HAVE LOST 10% SINCE THE
1970'S, AND IT GDP CONTROLLED BY
WORKERS HAS STEADILY DECLINED
AND SHIFTED TO CORPORATIONS.
SO WE BECAME THE RICHEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD WITH OF THE BIGGEST
MIDDLE CLASS IN THE WORLD BUT
THE COMING THE BIGGEST PRODUCER
IN THE WORLD.
JOHN: WHAT WAS ONCE STANDARD
PRACTICE, NOT A SINGLE STATION
TOOK IT LIVE TODAY.
THIS MAKES IT LOOK LIKE A NORMAL
POLITICAL OPERATION, HOW WAS IT
WORKING OUT?
MARK: THE PRESS AND OTHERS ARE
ACCESSED WITH THE MECHANICS OF
TRUMPS CAMPAIGN.
AND THERE IS SOMETHING TO THAT.
NOW THERE IS THIS MEME OF, WE
ARE GRADING HIM ON A CURVE, HE
IS LIKE A NORMAL CANDIDATE BUT
NOT DOING PERFECTLY.
THIS IS MUCH BETTER, THIS KIND
OF EVENT WE WILL SEE MORE OF.
HE GOES TO MORE VENUES, AND
LOCAL COVERAGE AT A MINIMUM WILL
GET MORE ON-MESSAGE.
AND THIS IS A POWERFUL MESSAGE
TODAY, WE HAVE A BIG TRADE
DEFICIT.
IT IS NOT PERFECT OR AS GOOD AS
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN IN TERMS OF
EXECUTION, BUT IT IS BETTER,
WITH A CHANCE OF WINNING.
JOHN: GIVEN HOW BAD IT WAS JUST
A WEEK AGO, 10 DAYS AGO, GIVEN
HOW LITTLE THERE WAS OF THE
STANDARD SCAFFOLDING OF A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, I
SURPRISED AT HOW FAST IT HAS
TURNED AROUND.
SO THE POINT WHERE, IF YOU DID
NOT KNOW ANY OF THE HISTORY OF
HOW BARE BONES THAT OPERATION
WAS AND YOU JUST DROPPED IN
TODAY, YOU WOULD THINK YOU ARE
IN A NORMAL PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
IN TERMS OF REPORTERS COVERING
IT, THAT INFLOW I MENTIONED
BEFORE.
I DID NOT THINK IT WAS
PARTICULARLY GREAT, BUT IT WAS
NORMAL.
MARK: AND THE MESSAGE OF, DO YOU
LIKE THE TRADE DEFICIT?
DO YOU LIKE WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING JOBS?
DO YOU LIKE WHAT IS HAPPENING?
TO INCOMES IF YOU DO, VOTE FOR
STATUS QUO POLITICIANS, IF NOT,
VOTE FOR CHANGE.
IT IS A CORE MESSAGE.
IT IS NOT AS -- IMPOSSIBLE FOR
HILLARY CLINTON TO RESPOND TO,
BUT DIFFICULT.
JOHN: YOU CAN DIAGNOSE ALL THE
PROBLEMS IN THE WORLD, BUT TRUMP
DOES NOT HAVE THE ANSWERS.
HARDER THAN ISSUING PRESS
RELEASES IS AN ACTUAL AGENDA
WITH REAL POLICIES AND SOLUTIONS
TO SOLVE ANY OF THESE MANY
PROBLEMS HE IDENTIFIED.
IT IS A GOOD FIRST STEP, BUT
UNLESS YOU HAVE THOSE THINGS,
BIG DEAL.
MARK: AND A REFERENDUM ON THE
STATUS QUO, IF HE CAN DO THAT,
HE WILL NEED MORE SPECIFICS.
THAT IS NOT A KEY PART TO HIS
CHANCE OF WINNING.
JOHN: I STILL THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
MARK: THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN IS
GETTING BLOWBACK FOR AN ORDINARY
AND IN ANOTHER WAY,
EXTRAORDINARY CONVERSATION ON
MONDAY BETWEEN BILL CLINTON AND
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES, LORETTA LYNCH.
THAT MEETING TOOK PLACE AT A
PARKED PLANE ON A TARMAC AT AN
AIRPORT WHILE CLINTON AND LYNCH
WERE VISITING THE CITY FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
THEY BOTH SAID IT WAS A CHANCE
MEETING IN THE CONVERSATION WAS
ONLY ABOUT FAMILY AND PERSONAL
MATTERS.
THE ENCOUNTER THOUGH RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ONGOING
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION
INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S PRIVATE
E-MAILS THAT -- SERVER WHILE SHE
WAS SECRETARY OF STATE.
LYNCH SAID THE CONVERSATION
STEERED CLEAR OF THAT CASE.
BUT, -- DONALD TRUMP WENT
FURTHER IN HIS CRITICISM THIS
MORNING ON MY GALLAGHER'S RADIO
PROGRAM.
MR. TRUMP: IT WAS REALLY A
SNEAK, SOMETHING THEY DID NOT
WANT PUBLICIZED, AS I
UNDERSTAND.
>> IT IS.
MR. TRUMP: I THINK IT IS
TERRIBLE, IT IS HORRIBLE.
I THINK IT IS ONE OF THE BIG
STORIES OF THIS WEEK, THIS
MONTH, THIS YEAR.
I HAVE TALKED ABOUT A RIGGED
SYSTEM, AND THIS IS TERRIBLE.
>> THERE IS YOUR EXAMPLE.
MR. TRUMP: YOU SEE A THING LIKE
THIS, EVEN IN TERMS OF JUDGMENT,
HOW BAD OF JUDGMENT IS IT FOR
HIM OR FOR HER TO DO THIS?
WHO WOULD DO THIS?
MARK: AGAIN, TRUMP IS NOT THE
ONLY CRITIC OF THAT MEETING.
OTHERS HAVE SAID IT DID NOT SEND
THE RIGHT SIGNAL.
SPEAKER JOSH EARNEST TALKED
ABOUT IT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID IT WAS
SIMPLY A CASE OF POOR JUDGMENT.
WILL IT BE FORGOTTEN OR A
LINGERING PROBLEM FOR THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN?
JOHN: IT IS DIFFICULT TO JUDGE,
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF RUNWAY.
BUT LOOK, BAD JUDGMENT, HORRIBLE
JUDGMENT.
I DO NOT THINK IT IS A PARTISAN
POINT TO MAKE.
BILL CLINTON SHOULD NOT BE
HAVING A TOP -- PRIVATE
CONVERSATION WHEN HIS WIFE IS
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
LORETTA LYNCH SHOULD NOT BE
HAVING A PRIVATE CONVERSATION
WITH A FORMER PRESIDENT.
I AM MORE THAN WILLING TO GIVE
THEM THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT,
BUT NONE OF US WILL KNOW WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED, AND THAT
CASTS DOUBTS AND RAISES
SUSPICIONS, CONSPIRACY THEORIST
WILL RUN WILD.
IT IS JUST BAD, DUMB.
MARK: IF HILLARY CLINTON IS NOT
INDICTED, THEY WILL SAY
PRESIDENT OBAMA COVERED IT UP.
THEY HAVE TAKEN EXTRAORDINARY
STEPS, THERE WILL BE A STATEMENT
IT IS OVER.
THIS WILL ADD TO THE PARTISAN
TANK ON THE DECISION AND A WAY
THAT IS NOT NECESSARY.
IT IS SO UNNECESSARY.
IF FBI AGENTS START TO LEAK, AND
WE HEAR ALL THE THINGS THAT CAME
OUT, PEOPLE WILL SAY THE FBI
WANTED TO INDICT AND LORETTA
LYNCH SQUELCHED IT.
AND BY THE WAY, SHE MET WITH
BILL CLINTON RIGHT BEFORE SHE
SPOKE.
JOHN: THAT IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT
PROBLEM, IT WOULD BE A PROBLEM
IF THE FBI STARTS TO LEAK AND
THEY HAVE CREDIBILITY.
AGAIN, I AM FOCUSED ON THE
VOTERS IN THE ELECTORATE.
THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND WHO
WILL VOTE FOR TRUMP ARE
CONSERVATIVES, THEY WILL THINK
IT IS A CONSPIRACY, ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER, AND THEY WILL VOTE
FOR TRUMP.
PEOPLE FOR CLINTON WILL VOTE FOR
CLINTON.
NO ONE IS GOING TO LOOK AT THIS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ELECTION.
MARK: I THINK YOU'RE
UNDERESTIMATING THE INTENSITY.
JOHN: SOMETIMES I HAVE DONE
THAT.
REPORTERS ARE SPENDING THEIR
DAYS DIGGING UP AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE ON 2016 RUNNING MATES.
ONE PERSON ON HILLARY CLINTON'S
SHORTLIST IS DEALING WITH A LESS
THAN FLATTERING HEADLINE.
VIRGINIA SENATOR SEEN BY MANY AS
THE FRONT-RUNNER FOR CLINTON AS
A RUNNING MATE, ACCEPTED GIFTS
AND PAYING FOR TRAVEL EXPENSES.
A LOT OF THESE EXPOSURES ARE NOT
NEW, BUT UNTIL NOW, HAVE NOT
GOTTEN NATIONAL ATTENTION.
HIS OFFICE SAID HE WENT THE ON
THE REQUIREMENTS OF VIRGINIA'S
LAW, DISCLOSING THE THRESHOLD.
HE IS CONFIDENT HE MET BOTH THE
LETTER AND SPIRIT OF THE
VIRGINIA'S ETHICAL STANDARDS.
THIS STORY IS A REMINDER THAT
MANY OF THE PEOPLE ON TRUMP AND
CLINTON'S VP SHORTLIST WILL HAVE
SOME POTENTIAL LIABILITIES AND
POLITICAL BAGGAGE.
CHRIS CHRISTIE HAS BRIDGE GATE,
AND TIM KAINE HAS THIS.
HOW IS THIS COMPARED TO THE
LIKELY POLITICAL PROBLEMS THAT
COME WITH ANY RUNNING MATE
CHOICE?
MARK: IF THIS IS THE WORST THING
IN TIM KAINE'S VETTING FILE --
IF I WERE HIM, I WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT, WHERE DID THIS
STORY COME FROM?
I DON'T THINK "POLITICO" FOUND
IT ON THEIR OWN.
WAS IT FROM A RIVAL DEMOCRAT, A
REPUBLICAN?
I WOULD BE CONCERNED.
JOHN: I 100% AGREE WITH YOU.
NOT JUST BRIDGE GATE FOR
CHRISTIE, BUT OTHER THINGS IN
HIS HISTORY WERE PROBLEMATIC FOR
HIM TO BE SELECTED BY THE ROMNEY
PEOPLE.
I THINK THERE ARE MORE VETTING
PROBLEMS WITH THE PEOPLE TRUMP
IS CONSIDERING THAN THE PEOPLE
CLINTON IS CONSIDERING.
BUT THE KNIVES ARE OUT ON BOTH
SIDES.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO TRY
TO TAKE OUT EVERYBODY ON
CLINTON'S SHORTLIST.
MARK: I WAS A BIT SURPRISE, THEY
DO HAVE AN EXPLANATION FOR A LOT
OF THIS STUFF.
IT SHOWS YOU IN THIS POPULIST
AGE, IT IS A PROBLEM.
A FEW YEARS AGO THIS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM, BUT NOW IT
DOES NOT LOOK GREAT.
WE HAVE DEBATED WHICH DONALD
TRUMP POLL NUMBERS ONE SHOULD
PAY ATTENTION TO AT THIS POINT
IN THE RACE.
NATIONAL SERVICE, TRUMP IS NOT
DOING THAT WELL.
AND BATTLEGROUND STATE POLL
NUMBERS, WHERE TRUMP IS PRETTY
COMPETITIVE.
LATELY WE HAVE BEEN NOTICING
MORE DISSONANCE, THINGS LIKE HIS
FAVORABILITY AND TRAITS WOULD
MAKE OTHER CANDIDATES SEEM LIKE
A DEAD MAN WALKING.
YET TRUMP IS A STILL IN THE RACE
DESPITE BAD NUMBERS.
A FOX NEWS POLL HAS HILLARY
CLINTON BEATING DONALD TRUMP 44%
TO 38%, BUT STILL IN THE MARGIN
OF ERROR.
BUT, MANY SAY THE PHRASE
HOTHEADED ACCURATELY DESCRIBES
DONALD TRUMP.
MORE THAN HALF OF REPUBLICANS
SAY THEY WOULD PREFER SOMEONE
ALSO AS THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE
AT THIS POINT IN THE REPUBLICAN
PROCESS.
THAT IS NOT A GREAT NUMBER.
JOHN, WHAT NUMBERS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT, LEADING INDICATORS
FOR DONALD TRUMP?
IS IT THE TRAITS THAT ARE
PROBLEMATIC?
JOHN: IF YOU ASK THE QUESTION,
WHY IS IT THAT ON THE NATIONAL
BASIS TRUMP IS STILL ON THE
MARGIN OF ERROR, BUT DROPPING,
AND THE NUMBERS IN SOME ARE
QUITE LARGE, BUT WORRYING FOR
ANYBODY?
THE TRAITS SEEM TO BE DRIVING
IT.
CLINTON IS WORRIED ABOUT HONEST
AND TRUSTWORTHY, TRUMP SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT THESE, FOR SURE.
MARK: THE FACT THAT SO MANY
REPUBLICANS WANT SOMEBODY ELSE
IS NOT GOOD.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE FOR TRUMP TO
WIN?
I THINK HE CAN WIN WITH ALL
THESE BAD TRAITS.
I THINK WHOEVER IS ELECTED WILL
HAVE A LOT OF WARTS.
TRUMP'S ARE KIND OF ASTONISHING,
BUT CLINTON'S, WE ARE USED TO,
DECADES OF THINKING PEOPLE DO
NOT NECESSARILY TRUST OF THE
CLINTONS.
JOHN: UNLESS YOU THINK TRUMP
WILL SUCCEED IN BRINGING NEW
PEOPLE INTO THE PROCESS, UNLESS
YOU BELIEVE THAT, HE HAS TO GET
OVER 90% OF REPUBLICANS TO VOTE
FOR HIM.
RIGHT NOW, A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
HATE TRUMP.
HE IS A WAY UNDERPERFORMING WITH
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE THEY THINK
NEGATIVE THINGS ABOUT HIM.
MARK: HE NEEDS A STRONG VP PICK,
AND A DEBATE.
JOHN: WE WILL EXPLORE THE
APPARENT IMPERVIOUSNESS OF BOTH
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES TO
CRITICISM AND POTENTIAL
SCANDALS.
♪
MARK: IF THERE IS ONE THING WE
KNOW ABOUT THIS UNUSUAL
PRESIDENTIAL RACE, BOTH
CANDIDATES HAVE FACED EIGHT
TRUCK LOAD OF FLAK, BUT IT DOES
NOT STICK THE WAY IT DOES TO
PAST TOM -- NOMINEES.
THERE IS THE TARMAC DISCUSSION
WITH ALERT -- LORETTA LYNCH, BUT
THAT IS ONLY ONE OF THE STORIES
IN THE RECENT PAST.
IF YOU HAVE NOT BEEN KEEPING
TRACK, WE HAVE YOU COVERED.
>> CLINTON, BENGHAZI
INVESTIGATION, ONGOING.
PRIVATE E-MAIL SERVER
INVESTIGATION, ALSO ONGOING.
DEPOSED.
SAID BOSSES PRIVATE E-MAIL
SERVER GOT IN THE WAY OF WORK,
FRUSTRATED.
BILL CLINTON AND LORETTA LYNCH
AND THAT MEETING, QUINN TO THEM,
LOOKS BAD.
FINALLY, SUPER PAC RECEIVED
$2000 IN BAND DONATIONS.
MARK: BOTH CLINTON AND TRUMP
WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY ARE
HOUNDED, BUT MOST OF THESE ARE
NOT STICKING.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS TO STICK TO CLINTON
AND DOMINATE HER DAY IN A
NEGATIVE WAY?
JOHN: IF ONE OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND HER OR IF SHE GOT
INDICTED, IF HER SERVER HAD BEEN
HACKED AND CONFIDENTIAL MATERIAL
HAD BEEN EXPOSED TO FOREIGN
HACKERS, THOSE WOULD BREAK
THROUGH.
THERE IS A WHOLE MASS OF THINGS,
ANYTHING THAT RELATES TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
SOMETHING WHERE THERE IS A CLEAR
LINK BETWEEN DOLLARS AND
SOMETHING SHE DID AS A SECRETARY
OF STATE, THOSE COULD BREAK
THROUGH.
BUT THE STAKES ARE HIGH BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE THICK HIDES WHEN IT
COMES TO CLINTON SCANDALS.
MARK: REPUBLICANS SAY IT IS THE
WORST THING THAT HAPPENED IN
WESTERN CIVILIZATION, THE
DEMOCRATS ALSO GO THE WAGON.
I THINK THE BAR IS PRETTY HIGH.
THE BENGHAZI HEARING FAILED
BECAUSE IT WAS PARTISAN.
THE THING TODAY WITH BILL
CLINTON AND LORETTA LYNCH, YOU
HAVE JEFF COHEN AND OTHER PEOPLE
BEING CRITICAL.
TO ME, THAT IS AN ESSENTIAL
INGREDIENT.
FOR TO STICK TO HER, THE
DEMOCRATS MUST THINK IT IS
PROBLEMATIC.
JOHN: LET'S NOT UNDERESTIMATE
THE WAVE THESE THINGS HAVE STUCK
TO HER IN A LONG-TERM WAY.
HER HONEST AND TRUSTWORTHY
NUMBERS ARE HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE.
THE LATEST POLL, CLOSE TO 70% OF
PEOPLE SAID SHE WAS NOT HONEST
AND TRUSTWORTHY, SHE IS TRAILING
DONALD TRUMP ON THAT.
THAT IS ALL ABOUT THE
ACCUMULATED WEIGHT OF THESE.
MARK: BUT IT IS NOT DOMINATED
TELEVISION, AND THAT IS
SURPRISING.
JOHN: TRUMP IS OF COURSE, NO
STRANGER TO SCANDALS.
HIS TEAM IS FACING A TRIFECTA OF
UNFLATTERING STORIES THIS WEEK
ON HIS BUSINESS SEMINARS, HIS
CHARITABLE GIVING, AND
SOLICITING FOR DONATIONS.
WE WILL CATCH YOU UP.
>> DONALD TRUMP HEADLINES, THE
BAD ONES.
TERRY, TRUMP SAYS HE GAVE
MILLIONS, THE WASHINGTON POST
SAID, NOT REALLY.
>> HE IS NOT GIVEN HIS OWN
FOUNDATION SINCE 2008 ANY MONEY.
>> AS FAR AS WE CAN SEE, YES.
HE SOLICITED DONATIONS FROM
FOREIGN NATIONALS.
ONE ACCUSATION COMES FROM PAUL
RYAN, NOT THAT PAUL RYAN, THAT
PAUL RYAN.
HE SAYS IT IS AGAINST THE LAW ON
THEIR FOREIGN E-MAIL ACCOUNT.
YET THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT TRUMP
HAS DONE.
TRUMP INSTITUTE?
NO, YOU'RE THINKING OF TRUMP
UNIVERSITY.
SIMILAR, A DIFFERENT
CONTROVERSY.
MR. TRUMP: THEY ARE SMART,
INTELLIGENT, AND IN SOME CASES,
BEAUTIFUL OR GOOD-LOOKING.
>> HE HAD A SEMINAR SERIES WITH
A STEEP PRICE TAG, THEY LEACHED
20 PAGES OF THEIR TEACHING
MATERIALS FROM UNOBSCURED
MAGAZINE.
AND FINALLY 2008, TRUMP GOT GOOD
PRESS WHEN HE TRIED TO SAVE BILL
MCMAHON FROM FORECLOSURE.
BUT, THAT DID NOT REALLY
HAPPENED.
TRUMP DID NOT END UP BUYING THE
HOUSE, SOME OTHER RICH GUY DID.
BUT HE BROUGHT ATTENTION TO THE
DILEMMA AND ED NEVER LOST HIS
HOME.
JOHN: AND A LOT OF SCANDALS, A
LOT OF CONTROVERSIES.
WHAT IS THE BAR FOR HIM?
MARK: AS MUCH AS THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN SHOULD BE GRATEFUL
THINGS DO NOT STICK AS MUCH AS
THEY USED TO, I CAN UNDERSTAND
THEIR FRUSTRATION.
THEY PLANTED A STORY ON THE
FRONT PAGE ABOUT THE TRUMP
INSTITUTE, I HAVE NOT SEEN IT
ANYWHERE ON TELEVISION.
THE STORY HAS A MILLION HOAX, IT
HAS THAT VIDEO.
JOHN: IT HAS UPFRONT PLAGIARISM.
MARK: AND PROFITEERING.
BUT ALMOST NO PICKUP.
I CANNOT TELL YOU WHAT IT WILL
TAKE THREE STUFF JUST DOES NOT
STICK TO HIM.
MAN, THE BAR, I CANNOT EVEN TELL
YOU WHAT THE BAR IS.
HE COULD GO ON FIFTH AVENUE AND
SHOOT SOMEONE, HE SAID IT BEST
-- IT WOULD NOT NECESSARILY COST
TO MANY VOTERS.
JOHN: I DO NOT THINK THAT IS
NECESSARILY TRUE.
MARK: A REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST, A
LIBERTARIAN, A NOVELIST.
IN A MINUTE.
♪
JOHN: WELCOME BACK, WE ARE
PULLING UP TO ALLITERATION
STATION.
MARY MATALIN, A POLITICAL
STRATEGIST WHO RECENTLY JOINED
THE LIBERTARIAN PARTY, ON THIS
PROGRAM.
AND STUART STEVENS, EIGHT FORMER
CAMPAIGN STRATEGIST FROM MITT
ROMNEY'S CAMPAIGN.
AND A WELL-TIMED NEW NOVEL, "THE
INNOCENT HAVE NOTHING TO FEAR."
STUART: I THINK THE OLYMPICS
SHOULD BE IN ONE PLACE, I THINK
--
JOHN: BEYOND THE OBVIOUS
POLITICAL VALUE, AS AN ACTUAL
PRACTITIONER IN PRACTICE, WHAT
ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE OF THAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENING?
STUART: 04 A CONTESTED
CONVENTION, SHORT OF TRUMP
COMPLETELY FALLING APART OR
DECIDING HE DOES NOT WANT TO
RUN.
I FIND THAT EXCEEDINGLY
UNLIKELY.
JOHN: SO YOU HAVE GIVEN UP, NO
WAY TO STOP HIM NOW?
STUART: THE GUY IS GOING TO BE
THE NOMINEE.
JOHN: YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
MARY: TODAY, BUT THEN NEVER
TRUMP FORCES ARE NOT GOING AWAY.
IF HE CAN'T BE STOPPED, HE COULD
BE BLOCKED PHILOSOPHICALLY.
THAT IS THE POINT OF
LIBERTARIANISM, I'M NOT TRYING
TO MAKE A STATEMENT.
THERE ARE INCREASINGLY VOCAL
LEADERS IN THE PARTY WHO ARE
SAYING, GIVE US SOMETHING.
GIVE US SOME SEMBLANCE OF A
PHILOSOPHY AND PRINCIPLES THAT
ONCE WERE PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
JOHN: IF THEY TOLD YOU, HELP US
STOP DONALD TRUMP, WHAT WOULD
YOU DO?
MARY: I WOULD NOT DO IT, I ALSO
THINK THE PARTY IS IN POWERLESS
SHAPE, THAT WOULD JUST
ACCELERATE ITS DEMISE.
I WOULD SAY TO CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR THE PRINCIPLES.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF HIS SPEECHES
, WE ARE HEARING SOME ECHOES OF
SOMETHING WE RECOGNIZE AS
POTENTIAL CONSERVATIVE
PHILOSOPHICAL TENANTS.
MARK: TRUMP DOING ANY DAMAGE TO
THE PARTY RIGHT NOW?
STUART: HE IS DOING TREMENDOUS
DAMAGE.
THE NIGHTMARE SCENARIO IS WHAT
HAPPENS WITH HISPANICS, MIRRORS
WHAT HAPPENED WITH
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN 1964.
REPUBLICANS WOULD GET 30% TO 35%
IN 1964 OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTES, BUT EASIER THAN WHAT
WE'RE GETTING NOW, BETWEEN 5%
AND 10%.
IF THAT HAPPENS WITH HISPANICS
IN THIS ELECTION FOR
REPUBLICANS, IT IS A
GENERATIONAL DISASTER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU RECOVER.
JOHN: STUART STEVENS, MARY
MATALIN.
THAT WAS A SHORT BLOCK, WE HAVE
A LONGER ONE COMING UP.
RIGHT AFTER THIS.
♪
MARK: BACK WITH TWO VERY
ACCOMPLISHED PEOPLE, MARY
MATALIN AND STUART STEVENS.
TELL ME SOMETHING YOU WONDER
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP?
MARY: I WONDER WHAT HIS
NORTHSTAR IS.
I TAKE THE POINT, I
INTERNALIZING IT, THAT HE IS NOT
POLITICAL OR IDEOLOGICAL.
I DO NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT HIS
NORTHSTAR, BUSINESS, WHAT IS
ECONOMIC NORTHSTAR IS.
I APPRECIATED SOME OF HIS --
SOME PARTS OF HIS SPEECH THE
OTHER DAY, GLOBALIZATION, BUT IF
HE WANTS TO GO BACK TO THE
CONSTITUTION HE NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND THE REASON WE HAD
TARIFFS BECAUSE WE COULD NOT DO
TAXES BECAUSE WE CAME OUT OF A
WAR AND WANTED TO STIMULATE
CREDIT, HE IS NOT EVEN USING
THAT TEMPLATE AS A BASIS OF HIS
ECONOMIC TRANSITION IN THIS NEW,
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
MARK: SAME QUESTION, SOMETHING
YOU WONDER ABOUT HIM?
STUART: WHY IS HE SO EMOTIONALLY
UNSTABLE?
HE IS INCREDIBLY INSECURE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM?
HE IS SOMEBODY THAT HAS BEEN
GIVEN EVERYTHING IN LIFE, AND
YET HE SEEMS TO BE CONSTANTLY
FEELING LIKE SOMEBODY IS
CHEATING HIM.
I DO NOT UNDERSTAND THAT.
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
I DON'T THINK IT IS ANYTHING YOU
CAN FIX, BUT IT IS IN MANY WAYS,
SAD.
MARK: LIKE SOMEBODY TOOK HIS
FLIGHT AWAY FROM HIM OR
SOMETHING.
[LAUGHTER]
STUART: IT COULD BE, LIKE
CITIZEN KANE.
HE LOVES THAT MOVIE.
MARY: BUT I THINK WE
PSYCHOBABBLE TOO MUCH.
DO YOU KNOW ANY PERSON THAT IS
SAYING -- WE ARE ALL NUTTY IN
SOME WAY.
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT IS A
MANIFESTATION OF SOMETHING HE
HAS, WE DON'T RECOGNIZE IT, SO
WE CALL IT INSECURITY OR
NARCISSISM.
I JUDGE HIM BY HIS KIDS.
AMERICA SEES IT, TOO HE
DOESN'T.LASH OUT AT PEOPLE IN
MARK: A WAY THAT IS UNUSUAL FOR
THOSE SEEKING SUPPORT.
MARY: AND WE KNOW FRIENDS AND
OTHERS WHO LASH OUT AT US, WHO
DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW THEIR
WORDS AFFECT US.
JOHN: DO YOU THINK DONALD TRUMP
IS AS EMOTIONALLY STABLE AS A
GEORGE HERBERT WALKER BUSH?
OR AS EITHER ONE OF THOSE
BUSHES?
MARY: I THINK HE IS VERY
THEATRICAL AND KNOWS MORE ABOUT
WHAT HE IS DOING THAT WE GIVE
THEM CREDIT FOR.
JOHN: YOU BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP
WILL LOSE THE ELECTION BADLY?
STUART: THE PROBABILITY IS,
BECAUSE OF THE REASONS YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER, WHERE HE
IS NOT COALESCED THE REPUBLICAN
VOTE.
THE MARGIN OF ERROR FOR A
REPUBLICAN TO WIN NATIONALLY IS
SO SMALL THAT YOU HAVE TO DO AN
INSIDE STRAIGHT OF AN INSIDE
STRAIGHT, AND I DO NOT THINK HE
IS ON TRACK TO DO THAT.
JOHN: AND YOU THINK HE CAN WIN?
MARY: I THINK HE CAN WIN AND WIN
BIG.
YOU WANT TO GO BY THE
CONVENTIONAL TEMPLATES WE KNOW,
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
LIVING THROUGH A NEW PARADIGM.
WE ARE RUNNING AGAINST AN
INCREDIBLY WEAK, NEVER CAN BE
LOVED PERSON WHO THINKS THAT
MONEY AND MACHINE WILL BEAT
TRUMP'S HIM.
IT IS NOT ABOUT TRUMP.
PEOPLE WHO'VE -- WHO ARE
SUPPORTING HIM, WHO HAVE NEVER
SUPPORTED HER -- WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT IMMIGRATION THEY DO NOT
HEAR THAT IT IS RACISM.
WHEN THEY HEAR ABOUT PROFILING
AND SYRIANS NOT BEING ALLOWED IN
THE COUSIN CAN BE VETTED, THEY
DO NOT SEE THAT AS BIGOTRY.
HE HAS A SOMEWHAT AGO THE PEOPLE
WANT TO GO, AND SHE HAS NOWHERE
TO GO.
IT IS JUST A DIFFERENT DYNAMIC.
SHE SHOULD BE WAY AHEAD OF HIM
BY NOW.
DUKAKIS WAS WAY AHEAD IN 1988 --
THEY ARE ALL MERGING TOGETHER.
STUART: IN SIMPLISTIC TERMS,
MEN, WOMEN, WHITE, NON-WHITE.
WHICH -- WHICH ONE WILL SHE DO
WORSE THAN OBAMA?
SOMEWHERE IN THERE, THAT IS ALL
WE GOT.
AND WHERE IS IT GOING TO BE?
THAT IS WHY I WOULD LOOK AT
WHITE WOMEN, ROMNEY LOST THOSE
BY 14 POINTS.
YOU NEED TO MOVE THAT CLOSER TO
20 IF YOU ARE REPUBLICAN.
RIGHT NOW, HE IS WHAT, BREAKING
EVEN WITH THE WHITE WOMEN?
BUT HE HAVE TO DO A WHOLE LOT
BETTER, BECAUSE ROMNEY DID WELL.
IT IS LIKE BASEBALL.
HE HAS TO START HITTING 600 AND
700S WITH CERTAIN GROUPS.
MARY: THAT IS A DEMOGRAPHIC
MODEL THAT IS NOT --
MARK: YOU AGREE WITH THAT,
EVERYONE IS EITHER A MAN OR
WOMAN OR WHITE OR NOT WHITE?
MARY: BUT YOU CAN BE SOMEWHERE
IN BETWEEN NOW, AND HAVE YOUR
OWN BATHROOM NOW.
HISPANICS ARE NOT HOMOGENOUS
THINKERS, WOMEN ARE NOT
HOMOGENOUS THINKERS, MILLENNIALS
ARE NOT SUPPORTING HER JUST
BECAUSE SHE IS A WOMAN.
I HAVE TWO YOUNG WOMEN WHO LIKE
HER OR DO NOT LIKE ARE BASED ON
POLICIES.
THERE IS NOT A LEVEL OF
HOMOGENOUS THINKING IN THIS VERY
VOLATILE ELECTORATE, WHICH HAS
BEEN VOLATILE FOR SOME TIME.
HISPANICS CARE ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, AND WHITE WOMEN CARE
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, AND EVERYONE
CARES ABOUT THE SAME THING.
MARK: WILL TRUMP DO BETTER WITH
WHITES THAN ROMNEY, OR
NON-WHITES?
MARY: HE WILL DO BETTER WITH
NON-TRADITIONAL VOTERS, I DO NOT
WANT TO COMPARE HIM TO ROMNEY,
NECESSARILY.
HE IS NOT GOING TO LOSE TEXAS BY
SEVEN POINTS.
SHE MIGHT LOSE MAINE, OR ONE
DISTRICT.
DO WE WANT TO DO DEMOGRAPHICS AS
NECESSARY?
I THINK HE WILL DO BETTER WITH
SOME NON-WHITE VOTERS.
STUART: I DON'T THINK WHO IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT MATTERS MUCH.
IF I WAS HIM, I WOULD GO WITH
SOMEONE WITH VERY STRONG
FOREIGN-POLICY CREDENTIALS.
THAT IS HIS GREATEST WEAKNESS,
WHICH WOULD BE THE CASE FOR
ANYONE WHO IS NOT HELD OFFICE
BEFORE.
JOHN: PLEASE IS SAY A NAME,
DON'T DO THAT THING HE JUST DID.
MARK: TAKE YOUR TIME, THE SHOW
IS AN HOUR.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY: TED CRUZ.
THINK ABOUT IT.
MARK: WE WILL THINK ABOUT IT
DURING THE COMMERCIAL BREAK.
THANK YOU BOTH.
HIS BOOK IS AVAILABLE, CALLED
"THE INNOCENT HAVE NOTHING TO
FEAR."
JOHN: IT IS GOOD.
MARK: AND, ANOTHER LOOMING
ELECTION IN GREAT BRITAIN.
♪
>> EUROPEAN UNITY HAS BEEN A
POISON SHALL US FOR DECADES WITH
POLITICIANS.
IT IS TIME -- THERE'S BEEN A
GRAVEYARD OF POLITICAL
REPARATIONS.
JOHN: THAT WAS FROM 81996
DOCUMENTARY SERIES, WHICH
EXAMINED THE IMPACT OF BRITISH
POLICIES.
AND, TO ANALYZE THE BREXIT -- WE
FOUND THAT THE BORIS JOHNSON,
THE NEXT FRONT RUNNER TO BE
PRIME MINISTER HAD DROPPED OUT
FOR REASONS UNKNOWN AND
UNKNOWABLE, WIDE?
>> IT HAS BEEN THE MOST
ASTONISHING DAY OF A WEEK OF
ASTONISHING DAYS.
HE WAS NOT ONLY GOING TO DECLARE
-- HE WAS ALL BUT CERTAIN TO BE
THE NEXT PRIME MINISTER.
WHAT HAPPENED, HIS PARTNER IN
ARMS WITH WHOM HE HAD FOUGHT IN
THE REFERENDUM TO TAKE BRITAIN
OUT OF THE EUROPEAN UNION
DECIDED THAT BORIS WAS NOT QUITE
UP TO THE JOB, THAT HE WAS, BUT
HE DECLARED TWO HOURS LATER AND
BORIS THROUGH THE TOWEL IN.
ABSOLUTELY UNBELIEVABLE
DEVELOPMENT THAT THE BRITISH
POLITICAL VILLAGE ARE STILL
TRYING TO ABSORB SIX OR SEVEN
HOURS LATER.
MARK: WHO HAS THE INSIDE TRACK
AT THIS POINT?
MIKE: THE LEADING CANDIDATE IS
THE SECRETARY, SHE WAS ACTUALLY
CAMPAIGNING TO STAY IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION, SHE DID NOT
CAMPAIGN VERY INTENSELY, BUT SHE
IS A REMAINER.
I THOUGHT SHE DID VERY WELL THIS
MORNING.
SHE HAS A REPUTATION FOR NOT
BEING PARTICULARLY CHARISMATIC
OR COMPELLING, BUT I THOUGHT SHE
WAS GREAT THIS MORNING, SHE MADE
A COUPLE GOOD JOKES.
SHE, I THINK, IS THE FRONT
RUNNER.
AND LET ME SEE, THREE LEAVERS,
AND ONE OTHER REMAINER.
FIVE CANDIDATES, BUT I THINK IT
WON'T COME DOWN TO TWO.
JOHN: MICHAEL, WE WILL HAVE A
NEW PRIME MINISTER, A NEW LEADER
OF THE TORY PARTY.
WHAT IS THE LIKELIHOOD JEREMY
CORBYN WILL BE THE LEADER OF THE
PARTY IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OR
THAT HE WILL BE REPLACED, AND
LIKELIHOOD WE WILL HAVE BUT
GENERAL ELECTION IN THE U.K.
BEFORE THE END OF THIS YEAR?
MIKE: GREAT QUESTIONS.
ON JEREMY CORBYN, HE HAS LOST
THE CONTROL OF THREE QUARTERS OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE PARLIAMENTARY
PARTY, BUT HE STILL HAS ENORMOUS
SUM -- SUPPORT WITH A LEADERSHIP
WHO CASTS THE VOTE FOR WHO THE
LABOUR PARTY IS.
RIGHT NOW, IF HE DECIDED TO WAIT
OUT AND STAND FOR REELECTION AS
LEADER, I SUSPECT HE WOULD WIN.
THAT WOULD SPLIT THE PARTY INTO
TWO ARMS, YOU WOULD HAVE -- I DO
NOT SEE HOW THEY COULD CAMPAIGN
TOGETHER.
WILL THERE BE A GENERAL
ELECTION?
TERESA WENT OUT OF HER WAY TO
SAY THERE WOULD NOT BE, A NEW
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNMENT WHICH
SHE HOPES SHE WILL BE THE PRIME
MINISTER.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IN
THE LAST EIGHT DAYS IS THAT YOU
REALLY CANNOT PREDICT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IN BRITISH POLITICS MORE
THAN 24 HOURS AHEAD, FRANKLY.
WHETHER NEGOTIATIONS GET OUT OF
THE EU, AND DEVELOP, YOU HAVE
MORE CORRUPTION'S TO BRITISH
POLITICS.
IF THERE HAS TO BE A GENERAL
ELECTION, I WOULD NOT RULE THAT
OUT.
BUT AT THE MOMENT, NO PLANS FOR
THAT.
JOHN: MICHAEL ELLIOTT, A MAN
TOUCHED BY GREATNESS, AND HAD A
RIGHT IN THE POISONED CHALICE.
BACK TO THE ELECTION HAPPENING
CLOSER TO HEAR.
IF YOU'RE WATCHING US ON
TELEVISION, YOU CAN ALSO WATCH
US ON THE RADIO RADIO, BLOOMBERG
99.1 FM.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: OUR NEXT GUEST JOINING US
FROM THE D.C. BUREAU, STEVE
MCMAHON, AND FROM SAN DIEGO,
FORMER PRESS SECRETARY FOR
GEORGE BUSHES 2007 CAMPAIGN,
CAMPAIGN STRATEGIST MINDY TUCKER
FLETCHER.
THE VIDEO YOU SEE NOW IS FROM A
TOUR SHE GAVE TO C-SPAN OF BUSH
HEADQUARTERS IN AUSTIN, TEXAS.
HERE IS A FLASHBACK FROM A
SIMPLER TIME.
>> WE ARE PRETTY HIGH-TECH HERE,
WE HAVE OUR OWN TELEVISION
STUDIO.
AND THIS IS THE BRAINS OF THAT
OPERATION, WHERE THEY CAN FEED
VIDEO AND AUDIO FROM HERE.
THEY MONITOR THE ROOM NEXT DOOR,
A STUDIO I CAN SHOW YOU.
THIS IS THE TECHNICAL ASPECT OF
THAT, WHERE THEY KEEP TRACK OF
OUR OWN TELEVISION AND AUDIO
NEEDS.
MARK: MINDY TUCKER FLETCHER,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I WILL ASK YOU A VERSION OF THE
QUESTION I ASKED EARLIER, WHAT
IS SOMETHING YOU WONDER ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON?
MINDY: THE THING I'VE BEEN
WONDERING FOR A LONG TIME, IS
WHO SHE HAS AROUND HER TO HELP
HER ARTICULATE HER VOICE.
I THINK SHE IS SMART AND
INTELLIGENT, SEEMS TO BE FUNNY
AT TIMES, I DON'T KNOW THAT SHE
IS FOUND AT THE RIGHT STAFF
PERSON THAT ENABLES HER TO BE
THE BEST HER.
I THINK THAT HOLD HER BACK FOR A
LONG TIME.
I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT OF
SOMEBODY WITH INSIGHT INTO HER
TEAM.
MARK: WHAT IS SOMETHING YOU
WONDER ABOUT HER?
STEVE: I THINK SHE HAS A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AROUND HER, ONE OF THE
BEST STRATEGISTS IN THE PARTY.
AND MANY OTHERS.
WHAT DO I WONDER ABOUT HER?
I WONDER IF SHE IS FRUSTRATED
WHEN DONALD TRUMP IS SPEAKING TO
PEOPLE'S EMOTIONS, AND SHE IS
HAVING TO BE THE REASONABLE,
RATIONAL, CALM, DELIBERATE
LEADER THAT A PRESIDENT HAS TO
BE.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT RUNNING AS A
PRESIDENT, HE IS RUNNING AS A
CARNIVAL SHOW.
AND SHE IS TRYING TO PROJECT AND
DEMONSTRATE SOLID LEADERSHIP.
SOMETIMES, THERE IS A SAYING
THAT THEY WILL QUICKLY FORGET
WHAT YOU TOLD THEM, BUT THEY
WILL REMEMBER HOW YOU MADE THEM
FEEL.
DONALD TRUMP REMEMBERS THAT AND
IS MAKING PEOPLE FEEL SOMETHING.
I THINK THAT IS FRUSTRATING ON
SOME LEVEL FOR THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
JOHN: FROM THE HEADLINES TODAY,
BILL CLINTON AND LORETTA LYNCH,
POLITICALLY, HOW BIG A POLITICAL
MISTAKE FOR BILL CLINTON TO SEEK
THAT MEETING, AND HOW BIG A
POLITICAL MISTAKE POLITICALLY
FOR LORETTA LYNCH TO ACCEPT HIM
ONTO HER PLANE?
STEVE: I THINK IT WAS A MISTAKE
FOR BOTH OF THEM.
I AM SURPRISED THAT THE JUDGMENT
THAT WAS EXERCISED IN THAT CASE.
I AM SURE NOTHING INAPPROPRIATE
HAPPENED, BUT I AM ALSO SURE THE
WAY IT LOOKS TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO SUSPECTED THESE THINGS, AND
THE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, IS NOT
GOOD.
THERE IS NO GETTING AROUND THAT.
JOHN: MINDY, WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT?
MINDY: IT JUST PLAYS INTO THE
NARRATIVE.
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY DISTRUSTFUL
OF HIM, GIVEN HIS BACKGROUND.
THEY TEND TO BE DISTRUSTFUL OF
HER, GIVEN WHAT SHE HAS BEEN
SHROUDED WITH OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS.
IT WAS A DUMB MOVE, AND EVEN IF
NOTHING HAPPENED, EVERYONE WILL
THINK SOMETHING HAPPENED.
IT WAS JUST A REALLY DUMB MOVE.
ON A CAMPAIGN OF THIS, RUNNING
AGAINST THE PERSON THEY'RE
RUNNING AGAINST, THEY HAVE TO BE
SMARTER THAN THAT.
JOHN: WILL IT MATTER A FEW
MONTHS FROM NOW?
MINDY: IF YOU PLAY INTO A
NARRATIVE OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
IT STARTS TO MATTER.
THEY HAVE TO BE CAREFUL, THEY
CAN DO THINGS LIKE THIS AGAIN.
MARK: YOU WORRY ABOUT NATIONAL
POLITICS AT A PRETTY HIGH LEVEL,
YOU ARE IN CALIFORNIA DOING
POLITICS THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF DONALD
TRUMP BEING THE NOMINEE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
MINDY: IT IS FASCINATING, HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH A TROMPE-LIKE CHANGE --
TRUMP-LIKE CHANGE.
WE HAVE A SENATE RACE AND SHOULD
BE COMPETITIVE, BUT NO ONE
RUNNING THAT IS COMPETITIVE.
IT IS A TRUMP-LIKE MENTALITY,
BUT IT IS NOW HAPPENING AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
IT IS A FIGHT FOR THE SOUL OF
OUR PARTY.
THE PEOPLE TO GO ALONG TO GET
ALONG ARE BEING VERY DANGEROUS
AND ENTERING INTO SOMETHING THAT
THEY DO NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
ARE GETTING INTO, THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF WHICH WILL BE
TERRIBLE.
HE IS A TERRIBLE NOMINEE, DOES
NOT REPRESENT THE BEST OF OUR
PARTY.
I FIND MYSELF AT HOME NOT
ALLOWING MY CHILDREN TO WATCH
HIS SPEECHES.
AND THAT IS SUCH A FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM WITH OUR NOMINEE, ITS
BASED AT THINGS WAY BIGGER THAN
PARTY.
JUST CONCERNS THAT ANY NORMAL
MOM SITTING AT HOME ON HER COUCH
WOULD HAVE ABOUT THIS PERSON
WANTS TO BE PRESIDENT.
JOHN: STEVE COME I KNOW YOU
WANTED TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
BEFORE ABOUT WHETHER THE BILL
CLINTON AND LORETTA LYNCH THING
WOULD MATTER.
BUT ANSWER THIS, ANYTHING IN
YOUR VIEW THAT COULD HAPPEN
BETWEEN NOW AND THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS IN THE E-MAIL-RELATED
CONTROVERSY THAT WOULD HAVE A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON HILLARY CLINTON, NEGATIVELY?
STEVE: I DO NOT THINK IT WILL
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON THE CAMPAIGN.
MINDY IS RIGHT, IT DOES FEED THE
NARRATIVE OF THE CRITICS.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE, I AM SURE
NOTHING UNFORTUNATE --
INAPPROPRIATE HAPPENED.
AS FOR THE E-MAIL THING, I DO
NOT SEE ANYTHING DEVELOPING.
AS YOU GET CLOSER TO THE
CONVENTION AND A NOMINATION, IT
BECOMES LESS AND LESS LIKELY
ANYTHING WILL DEVELOP THAT WILL
BE MEANINGFUL AND SIGNIFICANT.
THIS INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR AN AWFULLY LONG
TIME.
THERE ARE MANY FBI AGENTS
INVOLVED, IF YOU BELIEVE
EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN LEAKED,
BUT THEY DO NOT HAVE ANYTHING.
IF THEY DID HAVE SOMETHING, MY
GUESS IS, WHAT I KNOW ABOUT THE
ROLES FOR PROCEEDING AND
POLITICAL CASES WHEN THERE IS A
CAMPAIGN GOING ON, IF THEY HAD
SOMETHING, THEY ALMOST CERTAINLY
WOULD'VE DONE SOMETHING MUCH
SOONER THAN NOW.
MARK: BACK TO WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, IS YOUR
PREFERENCE THAT NO REPUBLICAN
PARTY MEMBER ENDORSED HIM?
MINDY: THAT WOULD BE GREAT,
WHICH WOULD LEAD TO A LARGER
CONVERSATION WITHIN THE PARTY
ABOUT WHAT TO DO FOR THE
CONVENTION.
MARK: THAT YOU PLAN TO VOTE FOR?
MINDY: THE CONVERSATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT USUALLY MY
VOTE DOESN'T COUNT, AND NOW
PEOPLE ARE RELIEVED.
IT DOES NOT MATTER HOW I VOTE
BECAUSE HILLARY WILL WIN
CALIFORNIA.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT TO DO,
REPUBLICANS DO NOT KNOW WHAT TO
DO.
THEY ARE FRUSTRATED, THEY DO NOT
WANT HILLARY CLINTON OR DONALD
TRUMP.
IT IS A HORRIBLE PLACE TO BE.
MARK: WHO ARE YOU GOING TO VOTE
FOR?
MINDY: I AM HOPING FOR A DUSTUP
AT CONVENTION.
I AM HOPING FOR A BETTER CHOICE.
MARK: MINDY TUCKER FLETCHER, AND
STEVE MCMAHON, THANK YOU.
MORE AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: REMEMBER THAT TIME WHEN
DONALD TRUMP OFFERED TO SAVE AT
MCMAHON'S MANSION FROM A
FORECLOSURE?
YOU CAN READ THAT AT
BLOOMBERG.COM.
AND, WATCH BLOOMBERG BEST YOU
CAN SEE BILL GATES, AN IMPORTANT
GUY.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
UNTIL THEN, SAYONARA.
♪
MARK: I AM MARK CRUMPTON.
YOU'RE WATCHING "BLOOMBERG WEST
TOKEN
THE PENTAGON ANNOUNCED TODAY
THAT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SERVE OPENLY IN THE
U.S. MILITARY.
>> OUR MISSION IS TO SERVE THIS
COUNTRY AND WE DON'T WANT
BARRIERS ON RELATED TO A
PERSON'S QUALIFICATION TO SERVE
PREVENTING US FROM RECRUITING OR
RETAINING A SOLDIER, SAILOR,
AIRMAN OR